ce qui a des gens qui disent c'est la
France qui t'a donné quitte qui a fait
ce que tu es aujourd'hui j'aime la
France et j'aime venir en France et je
vais revenir en France mais en fait en
France je me sens pas en sécurité et la
preuve regardez ce qui m'a tout ce qui
m'arrive on vient mettre le feu tu payes
tes impôts là-bas et en plus donc
pourquoi les gens de non mais je paye
toujours mes impôts en France
d'une fille qui se fait de violer elle
porte
elle a le droit de gagner de l'argent
elle a le droit de le montrer alors le
montre en or elle peut faire ce qu'elle
veut encore une fois elle l'a pas volé
on peut pas lui reprocher
sur le fait que des gens rentrent chez
elle brûle sa maison alors l'insulte et
et tout ça ça vraiment c'est
inadmissible on en convient et le
harcèle etc après quand tu fais un
métier d'image tout sur tout le reste
les insultes sur les réseaux tout ça
mais aussi on en a tous Voilà et ça
c'est le jeu à un moment si tu veux sur
les réseaux si tu veux que y ait que des
gens qui disent bah tu es parfait tu es
magnifique tu as une belle barbe Cyril
et ce soir
mais c'est ça ça c'est normal
pas tout le monde peut m'aimer
c'est très grave
il aurait pu avoir un meurtre
vraiment il faut quand même être
attaquer pour aller mettre le feu chez
moi tout autour
mais ça les mecs ils veulent bien savoir
ce que vont avoir les mecs là parce que
ça pour moi c'est c'est grave bah je
pense qu'ils vont les retrouver ben moi
déjà quand on m'a braqué c'est le
policier carrément qui a qui a qui a
donné le scoop à un blogueur donc
maintenant en France même les policiers
ils parlent avec des blogueurs
non mais pour répondre à Mathieu je
pense qu'il y a une petite nuance entre
cautionner et personne ne cautionne ça
des incendies des agressions évidemment
à personne et s'interroger sur le fait
quand on a beaucoup d'argent et tant
mieux pour vous mais de le montrer
systématiquement de donner
non mais vous gagnez vous gagnez
beaucoup d'argent quand même je gagne
bien mal maintenant on gagne plus notre
vie comme avant
tu gagnes combien même maintenant c'est
énorme
non mais on peut gagner beaucoup
d'argent et le garder pour soi et pas
forcément le montrer partout et exhiber
ce qu'on adresse
on peut s'interroger là-dessus c'est pas
cautionner les incendies arrête de faire
le parallèle horrible avec le viol enfin
c'est c'est ignoble de faire ça on peut
se demander si aujourd'hui quand on est
très jeune et qu'on gagne beaucoup
d'argent oui ça souciait oui vous savez
que vous exaspérez énormément de gens
est-ce que c'est bien de les montrer
c'est normal de se faire un Sandji de se
faire braquer parce que donc en fait
quand tu habites en France comme il y a
pas de sécurité tu as pas le droit
d'avoir de l'argent on a pas le droit et
tu as pas le droit de montrer que tu as
réussi dans ta vie pourquoi
pas mettre un policier derrière chaque
citoyen
est-ce que montrer qu'on a réussi dans
la vie c'est Snapper des montres en
diamant toute la journée et des des
en particulier mais vous savez qui vous
faites ça enfin en général les enfants
vous faites ça bah si bien sûr que si
mais peu importe
il y a des vidéos Maeva Le Monde des
fringues de luxe tout ça mais ça c'est
ton métier c'est ça c'est mon travail de
montrer ma vie alors oui mais après donc
c'est normal comme tu dis que tu fasses
insulter que tu te fasses sauter des
gens qui aide-moi voilà exactement je
suis pas faite cambrioler parce que en
France j'ai pas de j'ai pas
pas besoin de rester à Dubaï parce que
je suis en train de sa maison
je savais qu'elle était pas là qu'ils
ont dû voir qu'elle était pas là ils ont
mis le feu chez elle j'aurais pu mourir
non mais il aurait pu avoir quelqu'un
chez moi et ça aurait pu très mal se
finir